well we saw the cheeseburger and that's
all fine and well being soft tissue soft
flesh and bum but we actually wanted to
give it a go with something harder
something more substantial so using a
regular well-known auction site I
managed to purchase a skull a goose
skull and we're going to use that and
see how hydrochloric acid
hydrochloric acid when it's concentrated
is dangerous obviously when it's dilute
it's not dangerous you've got it in your
stomach though if it swells up inside
Wells up inside your esophagus the tube
that goes from your mouth to your
stomach
it can cause quite unpleasant pain we've
got a big conical flask now and what
we're going to do again put some
hydrochloric acid in there so what did
that first gram is ready with his big
tube so what we're doing is we're gonna
get into some zinc metal maybe we'll get
a little bit more at this time it should
f of s quite a bit and gram is ready
with the tube to collect it
now you can see the effervescence so all
the hydrogens should be coming off
hopefully in collecting in here what you
can actually see though is hydrogen gas
doesn't have any color or anything what
you're seeing is a bit of water vapor
because this reaction here is very hot
HCL reacts with metals like zinc and
magnesium to produce hydrogen
cross your fingers Graham going for it
again
it's stuck it's stuck yeah that was it
that was it that was the prop did you
not hear the pop no I think it's because
it's in such a big area then to get
another get as big a pop when I was at
school one of the boys wasn't thinking
what he was doing and he added sodium
carbonate to his zinc instead of
hydrochloric acid so no hydrogen came
out the teacher came along and said ah
I'll really get this started I'll add
concentrated hydrochloric acid now
concentrated acid reacts with a
carbonate to generate a large amount of
co2 gas so the teacher poured in the
concentrated acid there was a huge bang
and part of the apparatus which was
glass shot up to the ceiling and smashed
the glass on the ceiling and then came
down this is a very good lesson that
when you're using chemicals you have to
read what the label says on the bottle
or you can make a really quite serious
mistake
we'll see what happens when we add the
acid is the Baker
so I really quite like to show you a
little demonstration in the lab an
experiment which when it works is one of
my favorite so let's go to the lab and
we'll have a look if it is not yet
so the skulls been cleaned really well
and there's not a single bit of flesh or
soft matter left on it it's purely the
bone you can see it's actually bubbling
away so the bone is reacting with the
hydrochloric acid we're going to leave
that now I'm expecting that actually to
take longer than the cheeseburgers so
we'll leave it in there to stew and come
back in a bit and see how it how it
looks so the reaction is reaction of
cobalt chloride and we're going to
dissolve it up and then see what happens
if I add concentrated hydrochloric acid
HCL to it so here is the cobalt chloride
you can say the rather nice reddish
crystals doesn't quite match my lab coat
Oh a piece it's flipped over at some
point I didn't see when that happened
but it was at an angle like that
originally with the beak still there and
the head down here and it's now
dissolved to such an extent that the
whole lot of it can fit parallel to the
surface of the liquid so it's clearly
changed color and you can still see it
bubbling and frothing first of all and
go to add water so and it is dissolved
and I'm going to put half into this tube
so we've got two tubes with the same
amount of material so it looks as if
there's not much of it left so let's
take a look around this side okay so
most of the skull has gone the only
thing that's remaining there is the beak
so if we lift it out and take a look oh
okay so from the look of it it's only
the beak that's left and there's the jaw
let's stuff that up and take a look Oh
kind of gloopy so there we go
the beak is clearly made of something
different from the skull so the skull
being bone is mainly calcium phosphate
and the beak I think and is mostly
keratin so it's a lot of protein and the
HCL just hasn't really touched it I mean
it's giving it a bit of a sticky layer
from the feel of the beak through the
tongs but the skulls completely
dissolved and it's just in here in the
soup so in this one I'm going to put
some water and you can see that when I
put in some water has got a bit lighter
than that because I've diluted it so
let's see what happens if we add some
concentrated hydrochloric acid so I'll
try and add it so we have the same
volume in both so we would expect if we
add the HCL that it should make the
color go lighter but as you can see is
gone not only blue but it's gone much
darker blue then the pink so we have
diluted something and it's got darker
and the reason it has got darker is
because the chloride ions have reacted
with the cobalt so now we have in there
cobalt with four chlorine atoms rammed
it and to begin with we had cobalt with
water around it and chloride ions
swimming in solution so I think that
this is really quite a nice color change